sie sind ja der erfinder von enormem an
und ich habe noch einmal auf die tasse
geguckt fällt ihnen auffällt ihnen der
unterschied auch wenn sie auf die tasse
gucken und wenn sie sich selbst aktuell
im spiegel anschauen mein bart ist grau
es gibt noch was anderes
april ist die brille bull ist weg soll
das ist jetzt erklärt dass das
eigentlich ist total privat aber
wahrscheinlich kann jetzt auch einfach
einmal aufklären so ich hatte mich hatte
ich trage brille seit meinem achten
lebensjahr 54 das system der 46 jahre
sein sie hat mich nie gestört ich habe
mich total dran gewöhnen das einzige
problem war in den letzten jahren
konnten die brillengläser meine
sehschwäche nicht mehr richtig
korrigieren wer eine brille trägt weiß
das ja sinn und zweck einer brille ist
das genau das geschieht so also musste
ich mich darum kümmern dass weil ich
nicht bereit war das einfach zu
akzeptieren weil meine ich nicht happy
war mit meiner sicht so dann gab es
alternativen dazu da habe ich mich darum
gekümmert und dann hat man festgestellt
dass ich dass das nicht richtig
funktioniert weil ich ein kleines
problem im auge habe und die lösung
dafür waren kleiner eingriff dieser
eingriff hat dazu geführt dass kein
lesern gewesen oder sonst was hat dazu
geführt dass ich im moment ohne brille
sehr sehr sehr gut sehe das heißt nicht
dass ich nie wieder brille tragen wäre
das heißt nur dass sie unter umständen
alltag brauche ich keine mehr und es ist
tatsächlich bin habe ich immer nicht
dran gewöhnen ich bin in mein gesicht
komische ohne hunde aber wenn ich jetzt
die brille aufsetzen mit fensterglas
habe ich das gefühl als ich durch eine
glasscheibe gucken und das nervt dann
auch ich brauche ja nicht mehr und
deshalb trage ich im moment keine aber
es gibt die möglichkeit dass ich noch
mal dass es leicht verbessert werden
kann durch eine brille das auch nicht
entschieden und wenn das eintritt werde
ich wieder brille tragen und wenn das
nicht eintritt wenn ich keine mehr dran
so das war's
und sonst schicken sie mir eine neue
tasche ziehen dann die klopp variante
ohne brille falls das dauerhaft
das problem von vereinigt haben immer
darüber informiert also dass das jetzt
die ganzen schönen artikel neu
produziert